In case all of you in America missed the turkeys
running down the street for dear life, tomorrow
is Thanksgiving.
Without even a close second, Thanksgiving
is my favorite holiday of the year.
I find focusing on the 3 F's: Family, friends
and food, usually brings out the best in just
about everyone.
Between the triptophan from the Turkey, your
booze of choice and football in the background,
all of us, at least in my experience, are
just a little better on this day we've set
aside to give thanks for all the goodness
in our lives.
Thanksgiving is the ultimate reminder of what
it means to be American.
While most of us have the usual staples of
turkey, mashed potatoes, stuffing and cranberry
sauces around the table, we also bring in
traditions from our own cultures, ethnicities
and nationalities.
This blending of flavors, languages and customs
from all over the world is what makes Thanksgiving
uniquely American, no offense to Canadian
Thanksgiving.
The melting pot we've created here has given
more freedom to more people from more walks
of life than any other country in the history
of the world.
Today people still yearn to come to America
to take part in our freedom and pretty much
nobody wants to leave no matter how often
celebrities say they will.
This doesn't mean we are perfect, or anywhere
close to it, but it does mean that our tradition
of freedom, rooted in the pursuit of life,
liberty and happiness is a pretty good starting
point for how to build a truly liberal and
tolerant society.
While politics will undoubtedly be discussed
around the Thanksgiving table this year, I'm
going to do my best to try to veer the conversation
always to what brings us together, rather
than what rips us apart.
Maybe your uncle is pro-life and you're pro-choice.
Maybe your sister voted for Hillary, but you
voted for Trump.
Maybe you want low taxes, and your dad wants
to redistribute wealth.
Whatever those differences are, they are actually
the very reason that this country is so great.
We all get to have our own opinion and fight
for what we believe.
But beyond just the ability to be tolerant
of people who are different from us, it's
more important that we can still learn from,
live with, and even love people who think
differently from us.
I hope you have a wonderful day tomorrow,
filled with the those three F's I mentioned
earlier -- friends, family and food, and maybe
even one more F if you get lucky.
Either way, let's give thanks tomorrow for
all the goodness we have, but often forget
to even acknowledge.
Happy Thanksgiving to you and all your loved
ones...